c'est l'heure de notre second débat y
est vous vous le savez volontairement
décalée de l'actualité du jour on a
réussi à maintenir sa malgré sept cette
saison très riche en actu double sur le
secteur du tourisme aujourd'hui avec
cette question la pandémie marketel la
fin du tourisme de masse avant de
confronter les avis de nos experts un
portage en corse où depuis le début de
ce mois trois sites fragiles impose des
quotas de visiteurs des noms qui font
rêver les aiguilles de bavella la vallée
de la restonica et les îles lavezzi vous
on retrouve samia de sheer
c'est le joyau de la réserve naturelle
des bouches de bonifacio lille l'avait
dit est un petit paradis très convoité
jean-michel goulliaud lee et son équipe
sont chargés de la protéger
monsieur c'est une zone interdite à
l'ancrage des tuiles à mains vous devez
jeter l'ancré dans les zones de sable
entre les bouées jaunes
dont les années soixante dix lille est
payé 400 personnes par an aujourd'hui
290 1000 touristes viennent chaque année
ipes et la jaune
bonjour à tous sonné le débarquer sur
une zone de protection renforcée des
lave et c'est un espace fragile et
protégés c'est pour cette raison qu'il
ya des règles très strictes à respecter
donc dans un premier temps je vous
demandais de rester uniquement sur les
sentiers les plages et uniquement sur
lino principal pour protéger ce site
fragile l'assemblée de corse a décidé de
limiter sa fréquentation à 2000
personnes maximum par jour un quota fixé
par un conseil scientifique qui doit
permettre à terme de ramener le nombre
de visiteurs à 150 mille personnes par
an d'ici 2030 on n'a que neuf mille
mètres carrés de plage donc on peut pas
mettre un bug dans un oeuf et on ne peut
pas mettre 4000 5000 personnes par jour
ici c'est pas possible vous avez
forcément des infractions vous avez
forcément un dérangement qui est
important et donc il ya de toute façon à
une
une limitation qui est est aussi
quantitatif cela fait plus de trente ans
que jean michel culioli travail à la
préservation de lille védie un petit
bout de terre de 69 hectares où
certaines espèces d'oiseaux protégés
viennent se reproduire et il sait
exactement où trouver leur nid depuis
face andré qui nichent en dessous c'est
à sa famille de des albatros c'est la
plus grande colonie de méditerranée
occidentale qui viennent se reproduire
sur ces rochers ils ont besoin de
tranquillité pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
assurer la la couvaison et puis après
l'élevage des jeunes lille lavezzi
abrite aussi des plantes uniques comme
le limogne homme lambda n'y laisse
entier ne suffisent pas toujours à la
protégée du piétinement il faut qu'on
puisse avoir un petit sentier qui soit
juste qui soit juste à côté est encore
une fois bien sûr ce petit sentier on
peut pas mettre 300 personnes en même
temps à côté donc il faut qu'on ait un
moment donné une véritable réflexion sur
la canalisation mais aussi sur la
quantification et donc sur la notion de
quotas à quelques mètres des sentiers de
randonnée les touristes qui profitent
des eaux cristallines on pas entendu
parler de ces quotas pourtant déjà en
vigueur et accueillent plutôt bien la
nouvelle ya malheureusement oui des
déchets des déchets sur l'île et devant
le cimetière devant donc des sites qui
sont quand même normalement protégées et
je pense que effet ce serait bien que ce
soit mis en place pour justement éviter
tout ça on est venu à quelques années et
en effet il y avait moins de moins de
bateaux un petit peu moins de monde
qui est qui et des quotas je pense qu'à
terme ça serait une bonne chose un peu
moins enthousiaste les bateliers qui
amène les touristes sur l'île n'ont pas
souhaité s'exprimer
aujourd'hui les les retours sur les
l'avait dit cook 37 euros privé d'une
partie de leurs recettes les
transporteurs pourraient bien augmenter
ce prix un risque assumé par le maire de
bonifacio lille l'avait dit appartient à
la ville ici la quasi totalité des
habitants vit du tourisme
la priorité c'est permettre aux
bonifacien qui le désirent de pouvoir
aller sur l'île et de façon plus large
je dirais aux corses ensuite évidemment
nous entendons sur les chiffres qui ont
été avancés laisser une part importante
je dirais à aux touristes et je crois
que là aussi il faut pas se voiler la
face nous irons vers une politique
tarifaire peut-être plus importante qui
permettra aussi peut-être à la
collectivité de corse et à la commune de
bonifacio de tirer aussi la d d rien
pour pouvoir continuer à entretenir et à
mettre en valeur ce patrimoine
exceptionnel si l'expérimentation est
concluante la politique de quotas testé
cette année sur trois sites sensibles
corse pourrait bien être appliqué plus
largement sur l'île de beauté est ce la
fin annoncée du modèle du tourisme de
masse voilà le thème de notre débat tout
de suite je vous présente mes invités
sandra hoibian bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes directrice général du credoc centre
de recherche pour l'étude et
l'observation des conditions de vie
lionel rabier bonjour bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes directeur de voyages
d'exception et président des entreprises
du voyage d'île de france florent payet
bonjour journaliste au figaro bienvenue
à avoue aussi avec nous en duplex jean
viard sociologue directeur de recherches
au cevipof
bonjour vous êtes le coauteur de l'an
zéro du tourisme penser l'avenir après
la grande pandémie livre publié aux
éditions de l'aube et lætitia cru pas y
rester à mes côtés sandra hoibian des
quotas de touristes sur les sites les
plus fragiles on l'a vu encore ça existe
aussi sur d'autres sites est est-ce
qu'on peut y voir l'avenir de notre
patrimoine touristique d'une certaine
façon en tout cas il ya quand même une
prise de conscience et une forme de
règles qui se met en place donc on a
beaucoup déploré pendant très longtemps
le sur tourisme le fait qu'ils avaient
des lieux qui est devenait quasiment
infréquentable en fait tellement il y
avait de fréquentation et même pour les
touristes finalement c'est aussi plutôt
profitable de pouvoir profiter de ces
lieux avec un petit peu d espace sans
être les uns derrière les autres donc il
ya la fois des questions écologiques
possible de bien sûr préservation des
lieux mais pour le patrimoine c'est la
même chose il ya des queues incroyable
enfin il y avait avant le coc vite dès
que incroyable devant tous les poulets
monuments parisiens ou d'autres d'autres
d'autres types de festivals etc voilà il
ya aujourd'hui un peu une prise de
conscience qu' il faut réguler parce que
ça ne se règle pas de manière spontanée
en fait le touriste a toujours l horizon
que d'autres touristes même période de
l'année le mènera bien est ce qu'il
faudrait l'envisager sur par exemple les
sites emblématiques
de l'ile-de-france cité la tour eiffel
au château de versailles
c'est déjà le cas sur de nombreux sites
d'île de france notamment sur la tour
eiffel où vous devez réserver pour le
visiter clermont est donc ça permet de
limiter en fait de fait il ya un quota
oui un quota essais j'ai envie de dire
coc aussi aux aux agences de voyages qui
justement reçoivent les touristes en
france où les envois à l'étranger deux
conseillers de conseiller les voyageurs
pour leur expliquer que oui peuvent
visiter la tour eiffel mais peut-être
pas à l'heure de pointe
il ya aussi d'autres choses à voir à
paris que la tour eiffel au château de
versailles donc c'est un travail commun
à la fois de deux des destinations avant
tout qui on a on l'a vu pour marseille
ou pour paris mais aussi des agences web
et aussi aux voyageurs peut-être de se
renseigner aussi sur internet avant
d'organiser leurs voyages flore mayes
qu'effectivement
ça existait mais on se rendait pas
forcément compte d'ailleurs quand on va
visiter la tour eiffel on se dis pas
tiens je suis dans un quota hawaï est ce
que le mien mais est ce que ça peut
finalement devenir une habitude des
touristes alors qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas
le sentiment que ça le soit déjà ça peut
devenir une habitude et touriste à peu
devient une habitude tout court rappelez
vous pendant la pandémie on s'était
habitué à réserver au restaurant à
anticiper en quelque sorte les moindres
faits et gestes de la vie quotidienne il
ya quand même un élément qui est
important qui me semble important de
rappeler c'est qu'on parle de
réservations mais on rassure un schéma
de gratuité c'est d'ailleurs que ces
sites restent entièrement gratuit la
seule différence il nous faut
s'organiser s'enregistrer en général
quelques jours avant sachant qu'on
prévoit toujours un petit à petit
battement dans les calanques qui garde
je crois quelques dizaines quelques
centaines de places jusqu'au jour j donc
ça va je pense devenir une habitude et
qui risque de faire tâche d'huile c'est
à dire que beaucoup de sites on a parlé
de l'île de france on parle de l'exemple
des calanques on a vu la corse également
c'est également le cas dans les pyrénées
on peut envisager que c'est quelque
chose qui va se développer alors les
cales en justement aussi quelques images
avec un système de réservations réaction
aussi de visiteurs interrogé par nos
confrères de l' agence france-presse
hier ou avant-hier on a regardé sur le
sur le site s'était déjà plaint
donc
de toute façon voté venir tour mais on
est en effet de les lever un petit peu
plus tôt d'habitude quand même pour être
sûr de pouvoir en profiter mais comment
par bonheur je pense qu'on dérange
personne et que
on perturbe pas le système je pense
c'est ma femme qui a réservé 3 il ya
trois jours les billets parce qu'on est
au courant que maintenant c'était
réglementée et que pour voilà préserver
la nature il fallait réguler le flux qui
est vraiment très intense l'été sous
c'est une très bonne chose il ya moins
de monde donc c'est plus marcher c'est
plus cool pour être point d admirer la
nature la mer depuis moins de deux mois
c'est mieux et pour info les
contrevenants s'exposent à une amende de
68 euros jean viard la france est l'un
des rares pays au monde à recevoir plus
de touristes qu'elle ne compte
d'habitants
je crois qu'à la thaïlande c'est ça
aussi et donc l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est
pas d'arrêter d'en accueillir c'est
mieux les répartir sur notre territoire
qui est riche de nombreux sites est ce
que vous diriez ça alors on se remettent
alors une politique touristique si vous
voulez parce qu'il ya un ministre du
tourisme le mélanger avec le petit
commerce etc c'est pas ça l'enjeu et y
avait 60 millions de touristes
internationaux 68 y en avait un milliard
et demi andy de 2019 moi mon rêve c'est
y en ait trois milliards c'était mon
rêve c'est que les sommes allés voir les
hommes qui se visitent les uns les
autres et c'est même si je vois les
projets écologiques mais bon et le
problème c'est qu'il faut réguler ce
flux pss et il ya deux façons de le
réguler son par le prix d'ailleurs le
maire de bonifacio le disait clairement
comme c'est déjà le cas du ski et le ski
ça va augmenter parce qu'il y aura de
moins en veine station donc ça va être
c'est déjà hors de prix mais ça va être
intouchable soit par le numérique donc
soit on construit j'allais dire un
territoire numérique avant d'aller
quelque part vous allez taper vous allez
dire je veux aller là on vous y attend à
la tuque chez les restaurants sont
bondés tu pourras pas de garer et en
plus ce tu pourras peut-être pas
réservée pour elle à tel endroit mais si
tu vas la semaine d'après ou si tu vas à
capter le natif de tuer il faut
construire la diffusion dans le temps et
dans l'espace et c'est ça la grande
question parce que tout le monde veut
plus de touristes parce que ça fait du
business ou des choses comme elles sont
c'est normal lui % du pib et c'est à peu
près 8 % mais il faut effectivement se
mettre face à moi je suis très poids la
régulation ce qu'on a fait à ce sujet
tant à marseille que les gens racontent
c'est parfait mais c'est normal parce
que c'est actuellement c'est un peu
comme si sur l'autoroute y avait pas de
règles de circulation il n'y avait pas
de code de la route et rien on lâche des
poux qui ont dit il en faut 100 millions
plus les français qui vont à peu près
100 amis en voyage c'est pas raisonnable
et donc du coup à un moment on fait quoi
on classe par l'argent qu'on a un
discours qu est-ce que c'est le tourisme
de masse pour plein de gens c'est le
tourisme populaire ou savez moi je viens
me le tourisme populaire je suis pas du
tout pour sa diminution
intervient parvenir les tourisme
populaire la nouvelle ministre du
tourisme ot nivea grégoire c'est la
nouvelle ministre dans le gouvernement
bornes de est allé dans un camping de la
grande motte en occitanie la la région
qui reçoit le plus de touristes mais
c'est vrai que j'en viens à raison
olivier à grégoire elle est ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce là anna et du
tourisme et quand on sait la
particularité française de recevoir
presque autant de touristes qui lie à
d'habitants on peut s'interroger sur
cette petit cul l'arrêter en tout cas
dans les responsabilités de l'état
hébreu genre jean viard vous opiné du
chef vous êtes d'accord mais moi je
pense que c'est un vrai problème et
c'est pas qu'en france moi j'étais
représentant à bruxelles si vous voulez
sur ces sujets il faut qu'à un moment on
pense cet immense population qui
circulent et aussi pour faire partir les
autres est ce que les jeunes de banlieue
et partent pas en vacances la
démocratisation des vacances comme on ne
trouve qu'à trop de monde on ferait la
démocratisation mais vous savez un jeune
qui est pas partie sera pas un voyage
heures plus tard et qu'est ce qui va
faire à tourner dans sa cité tout l'été
après on dit oui son bar des univers
religieux etc oui d'accord mais ici la
mer s'ils partaient en turquie donc si
vous voulez un moment être exclues des
vacanciers aux seuls souvenirs de
vacances et le premier souvenir que les
gens vous donnent autant demander à
quelqu'un quel est ton meilleur souvenir
l'année dernière vous êtes sûrs de
tomber sur un souvenir de vacances c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est cet
immense désir des vacances alors qu on
le gère la petite boutique alors et
c'est un sacré défi parce que continue
de démocratiser
les vacances tout en préservant la
planète c'est pas si simple on va y
venir mais sandra hoibian peut-être une
question un peu plus d'actualité liées à
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat est ce
qu'on doit faire j'ai pas la réponse
mais c'est vous qui s'est fait qu'elle
est nous la donnait forcément anticipé
moins de départs en vacances des
français dans ce contexte ou alors
peut-être ils vont partir moins loin
moins longtemps qu est ce qui va se
passer alors en fait je crois qu'il faut
donner des grands ordres de grandeur il
ya trois types de population il ya
quatre français sur dix y ont grandi
français y en a quatre sur dix qui
partent pas en vacances de l'année et ça
ça change chaque année alors ça augmente
ça baise moi mais on savait que ça
allait plutôt augmenter puisqu il y
avait en plus des questions de
restrictions sanitaires après il ya
aussi quatre français sur 10 qui partent
mais qui partent à l'économie donc ils
partent en voiture ils partent en france
pas trop loin et ils partent plus tôt
chez la famille et des amis et cela ils
sont directement touchés par les
questions de pouvoir d'achat et donc
l'hôte amant l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie et du carburant qui représente
un quart du budget des vacances c'est
énorme pour eux un quart en moyenne mais
37 % chez les plus modestes donc pour
eux c'est vraiment un impact très
important effectivement ils vont partir
moins loin moins souvent moins longtemps
ils vont peut-être aussi renoncé à leurs
vacances cette année pour partir l'année
d'après et puis après on a deux français
sur 10 qui elles vont partir beaucoup
souvent et qui sont un peu dans cette ce
phénomène de revenge tourisme c'est à
dire je vais me rattraper après deux ans
que j'ai pas pu partir où j'ai pas pu
dépenser j'ai mis un petit peu d'argent
de côté en plus sur mon compte en banque
parce que j'ai pas pu dépenser en loisir
pendant deux ans et donc voilà donc on
peut avoir très bien une industrie
touristique qui est florissante qui
reprend et pour autant moins de français
qui partent en vacances il ya ce chiffre
donné par le ministère du tourisme qui
annonce un niveau de réservations en
hausse avec + 25 % par rapport à ce qui
est l'année de référence qui est l'année
2019 florent payet est ce que vous qui
avez un peu le regard du du journaliste
sur ce secteur est ce qu'on peut parler
d'une sortie de crise là aujourd'hui
instantanément oui parce qu'on sent elle
est palpable cette envie de cette envie
de partir les gens se sont réfrénés
effectivement cette fameuse épargne
covit qui concerne pas tout le monde
mais qui a bel et bien été mise de côté
donc instantanément la réponse pourrait
être oui la question c'est qu'est ce qui
va se passer ensuite et c'est surtout là
je pense que les professionnels expliqué
jacques études parce qu'ils sentent
venir par une somme de petits indices
quand même des réflexes lorsque vous
allez à l'hôtel vous allez peut-être pas
souscrire un petit déjeuner qui pèse
quand même pour près de 10% du prix de
la chambre vous allez vous contenter
d'un café donc à toute une série de
petits comportements comme ça qu'ils
commencent à traduire une méfiance et la
potentielle crise économique qui devrait
suivre à la rentrée m en sers on sait
pas encore aurait dans ce cas là des
effets au contraire de réfréner la
dépense de loisirs qui s'adresse pas aux
dépenses d'énergie ou d'alimentation el
arabi l'avoir anticipée d'abord je
voudrais confirmer les chiffres sur
l'été puisque effectivement en termes de
réservations en valeur on est sur une
hausse de + 20 % par rapport à 2019
alors on prend comme scop les français
qui réservent via une agence de voyage
ou un intermédiaire les fameux 2 sur 10
en volume on est sur des niveaux
équivalents à 2019 donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que bon il ya un
phénomène d'inflation 1 à toute personne
qui veut réserver un billet d'avion en
ce moment s'en rend bien et puis aussi
peut-être pour cette catégorie
privilégiée de français qui voyagent
l'envi de dépenser un peu plus qu'avant
parce qu'ils ont épargné certains pour
un colis et donc on voit les paniers des
paniers moyens qui ont augmenté
d'environ 20% par rapport à 2019 mais si
on parle des touristes et et étrangers à
travers les chiffres la france est la
première destination alors autant de
visiteurs l'hostis c'est le ministère du
tourisme acquis qu'ils fournissent et
séchez 90 millions mais la troisième
seulement en recettes 58 milliards
d'euros est ce que ça veut dire que les
touristes étrangers dépensent moins en
france que dans d'autres pays c'est la
france ça c'est un chiffre qui a
toujours été ainsi la france a toujours
eu le record mondial en termes de nombre
de visiteurs mais pas du tout en termes
de chiffre d'affaires ainsi commence à
s'expliquer les etats-unis qui sont de
très loin d'ailleurs le pays ni roi tout
simplement parce que parmi les fameux 80
millions de français il y en a beaucoup
20 d'étrangers qui viennent en france il
y en a certains qui ne font que passer
par exemple pour aller beaucoup
d'européens du nord qui vont en espagne
en italie au passé une nuit en france
et c'est d'ailleurs l'enjeu c'est
l'enjeu est effectivement de de notre
pays d'essayer de faire en sorte que ces
voyageurs qui ne font que passer reste
un peu plus longtemps et si possible
plutôt dans des zones qui sont
aujourd'hui peut on va dire que
concernés par le tourisme
florent payet j arrive excusez moi je
voulais qu'on commence à aborder la
question du tourisme responsable et
peut-être de la réaction des populations
qui vivent dans les sites les plus
recherchés par les touristes français ou
les touristes du monde entier et
notamment avec ce mouvement contre les
paquebots géants là on l'a vu à venise
on l'a vu à ajaccio on l'a vu à nice
est-ce qui est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
mouvement
en amorce en tout cas on sonne colère
qui se cristallisent qui est le résultat
est la conjonction de plusieurs facteurs
la difficulté de ce la difficulté de se
loger les prix qui augmentent
donc pour le foie et puis dans le même
temps c'est un petit peu ce que disait
jean viard tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
de politique structurante peut-être de
tourisme en tout cas une politique
économique du tourisme c'est à dire que
ces territoires en tire partie mais
c'est ça j'ai même persisté c'est une
espèce de schizophrénie c'est à dire que
c'est souvent des départements ou des
villes qui ne vivent c'est donc
s'étonner ça et vous avez pris quelques
exemples moi j'ai un exemple en tête
notamment c'est saint malo qui était
réputé avoir pris une politique
relativement restrictive contre bienne
be les mêmes habitants de saint malo une
partie en tout cas qui prétendent avoir
une démarche plus responsables que les
autres vont au contraire s'élever contre
une réglementation qui juge plus
restrictives le sujet est compliqué ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya des colères
qui s'expriment maintenant publiquement
je pense à barcelone je pense à la corse
effectivement je pense aussi au pays
basque voilà donc des territoires où les
citoyens font part de leur
mécontentement mais les mêmes citoyens
peuvent avoir un comportement
complètement schizophrène à certaines
périodes de l'année donnerait bien
est-ce que
on parle de tourisme responsable c'est
quoi les critères
d'abord effectivement le tourisme
responsable c'est un tourisme qui
préserve les lieux où vont les touristes
à dire à la fois au niveau économique et
c'est pour ça que originellement ce
qu'il y avait derrière le tourisme
responsable c'était vraiment cette idée
que les que les populations de
destination récupère véritablement la
valeur du voyage donc c'était quelque
chose d'essentiel et puis on parlait
aussi évidemment de la préservation des
écosystèmes
aujourd'hui le sujet qui émergent le
plus c'est la question du réchauffement
climatique donc c'est le sujet qui est
où il ya beaucoup d'articles shift
projet à greenpeace qui est alerte 1 /
sur l'impact carbone notamment des
voyages longue distance donc voilà c'est
toutes ces choses là mais c'est vrai que
le sujet le plus brûlant aujourd'hui si
vous me permettez ce terme c'est celui
du de l'impact sur le réchauffement
climatique jean viard est ce que ce
tourisme haut responsable il est
compatible avec les vacances pour tous
et moi je vous rejoins quand vous dites
j'ai envie que les humains continuent de
de se rencontrer partager mais comment
comment on tient c'est de ces deux
objectifs qui semble sur le papier la
spontanément un peu incompatible ans et
vous savez c'est pour n'importe quelle
activité humaine il ya un effet négatif
c'est former qu'un seul voiture tout ce
que vous voulez pas plus de touristes
coincés avec autorise aussi importante
leurs obligations des objets à si vous
allez donc faire attention pourquoi
particulièrement critiqué le tourisme
nature après effectivement plus on
démocratise mais le monde est immense il
ya 15 ans brouille à personne si vous
voulez c'est pas comme si toute la
planète et est couverte par tous d'une
foule de touristes mais moi qui leurs
vacances en bretagne je vous assure
souvent le matin je baignais tout nu
parce qu'à personnes sur une plage de 5
km toxines et il faut faire reconnaître
la mer un peu plus fraîches qu'en
méditerranée mais enfin c'est pour dire
il faut faire attention il ya des
lieux-dits perdant cité parce qu'y
compris on n'a pas fait très attention
mais oui barcelone moi j'ai travaillé
avec eux ils ont été élus contre le sur
tourisme il maintenant qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils ont analysé les fluxs et sont
rendus compte qu'il ya des gens qui
viennent à la journée sur les ramblas
pour manger des campings donc ils les
mettent d'un côté il ya des gens qui
viennent dans les hôtels qui souvent
reviennent plusieurs fois notamment le
tourisme d'affaires qui est très
important ils auront fait d'autres
objectifs de visite d'autres restaurants
pour pas qu'ils assurent les ramblas etc
ils ont diffusé les fluxs c'est
exactement le travail qu'il faut qu'on
fasse à plein dans moi si on ne peut pas
laisser une foule se libérer sans une
organisation c'est ça qu'il faut dire
alors il y en a plein regarder on a déjà
fait énormément de choses à depuis vingt
ou trente ans la pointe du raz on
affirme qu les les mules des voitures
etc je dis pas qu'on a rien fait ça
serait faux mais s'ils voulaient on peut
pas d'un côté dire on veut 100 millions
de touristes et faire partir plus les
français deux objectifs que je partage
et dire ah ben ça va se passer comme ça
c'est pas possible voilà mais moi je
crois que c'est pas ingérable voyez par
exemple qu'est-ce qui va visiter la
basilique de saint-denis à paris alors
qu'à pleinement notre dame de paris et
le problème du touriste et qui bien sûr
il ya une première fois il se détourne
internationaux au fond il bien une
première fois bon on lui connaît paris
la côte d'azur et la serva en gros la
question c'est que c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faut voir son voyage d'après
qu'est ce qu'on va les données
commanderie de voir les châteaux de la
loire des yeux qui ne connaît pas voyez
donc à toury ça se construit dans la
durée il faut lui offrir des choses
nouvelles pour qu'ils rêvent de revenir
ailleurs etc c'est cet énorme travail
qu'on a à faire mais si on veut 8 % du
pib ou plus et que c'est un énorme en
chambre parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui travaillent dans tourisme que
c'est là qu'ils apprennent à servir etc
il faut effectivement mettre des moyens
une politique des centres de recherche
etc rien de tout ça n'existe sandra
hoibian on parle d'écotourisme
c'est pas le premier argument dans le
choix d'une destination d'un d'un site
ou d'un hôtel clairement non non le
premier argument c'est
en fait il ya trois trois arguments
principaux la proximité avec la famille
et les amis donc pouvoir passer du temps
avec ses proches en fait le prix prix
parce que j'avais vous dire moi je
l'aurais cité en premier vous voyez mais
bon très bien bon les deux sont liés
et puis le confort du lieu et après il
va y avoir tout un tas de bonus si je
puis dire est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
des découvertes locales gastronomique
culturel par exemple les vacances je
rejoins jean vient c'est un des moments
où les gens découvrent la culture il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne font qu'une
visite de patrimoine dans l'année et
c'est pendant les vacances en fait
qu'ils vont aller voir le château
l'église et c'est donc à une forme
d'ouverture aussi un petit peu sur le
monde même si bien sûr il ya encore de
l'entre- soit en vacances un c'est pas
toutes les frontières ne tombe pas mais
non moins il ya quand même un peu de
découverte et puis depuis quelques
années il ya aussi une progression de
tout ce qui est loisible nature en fête
l'envi de se rapprocher de la nature de
faire de la randonnée de ce sont aussi
des loisirs qui coûte pas très cher qui
sont accessibles et puis il ya une
grande frustration pendant le coït donc
aujourd'hui à des territoires un petit
peu plus ruraux à un peu plus montagneux
qui attire un petit peu plus qu'avant
alors on n'a pas changé les proportions
c'est toujours la mère en premier mais
il ya un petit peu plus d'intérêt pour
cette année 3 la question c'est comment
changer les habitudes on entend ce que
dit jean viard est ce que c'est la
responsabilité des tours opérators
est-ce que ça la responsabilité des
localités de la communication aussi de
certains sites comment faire pour
effectivement essayé de plus mélanger
les touristes et de faire venir les
touristes à saint denis oui ah ça c'est
la question c'est peut-être perdre dix
mois c'est la dimension d'un état d'un
département que ces décisions peuvent se
prendre c'est compliqué mais j'ai un
chiffre en tête je parle sous votre
contrôle janvier à une semble qu'au
niveau mondial à 95% du tourisme qui se
concentre sur 5 % des territoires ça
résume quand même je pense si ce chiffre
est vraiment ça je pense qu'on peut pas
être très très bas je pense que ce
chiffre montre à quel point les gens ont
envie de découpe certains endroits on a
si cela qu'ils sont les puces publiciser
c'est à dire est que ceux-ci ont porté à
leur connaissance d'autres endroits
peut-être avec un tarif peut-être plus
attractif il y aurait plus davantage de
mélange donc à qui incombe cette
responsabilité rappelez-vous aussi
question d'imaginer tout
il ya tout un travail de marketing des
lieux en fait pour montrer les avantages
qu est-ce qu on peut y faire quelque
part il faut instagram et les
destinations cac est la responsabilité
de valeur je me prononcerai pas en
revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que
rappelez vous il ya un peu moins d'un an
il y avait ce qu'on appelait les
premières campagnes de d'e-marketing
cedac paradoxalement le parc national
des calanques par exemple communiquer
sur des images qui devait qui était
censé ne pas donner envie voilà ça
c'était il ya à peine y à peine un an au
pays basque légalement on ne communique
plus sur les destinations déjà très
connus que je ne citerai donc pas mais
en revanche ils communiquer sur
l'arrière pays voilà l'idée c'était
venez au pays basque va en revanche
allait plutôt viser la rapide ce qui est
intéressant c est ce que est ce que ça
peut s'équilibrer tout seul c'est à dire
que le pays bas c'est vrai que moi
j'adore cette région mais je n'y
retourne plus au début du mois d'août
parce que c'est plus possible
et donc est ce que ça serait qu'il y ait
finalement moment où est ce que au
contraire quand une destination est à ce
point imprimé dans dans les habitudes
des touristes qui continue d'y aller
même quand il ya beaucoup trop de monde
je pense que la question fondamentale
c'est quel touriste on veut faire venir
en france oui si on communique comme on
l'a fait beaucoup vers une clientèle
internationale vers les chinois vers les
américains on pourra jamais leur dire
venez à paris mais surtout ne venez pas
visité la libre et ses marques bien sûr
en revanche en revanche si effectivement
et je crois que c'est un peu la
politique qui veut être développée au
niveau national on s'intéresse plus à
une clientèle européen
là c'est possible de leur dire bon bain
l'année dernière vous avez vous j'ai
monté en haut de la tour eiffel va cette
année aller visiter les châteaux de la
loire où aller au pays basque donc
effectivement le groupe l'état avec
toutes les instances touristiques a un
grand rôle à jouer en termes de
marketing de la destination mais on
enlèvera jamais le rêve à un chinois ou
un japonais d'aller visiter la tour
eiffel je reviens la question marginale
de thomas vous nous aviez commencé
l'émission en parlant des fameux quotas
enfin peut-être que l'avenir repose sur
ce quota poussé où je rappelle j'avais
dit que c'était gratuit pour l'instant
ne paye pas pour visiter ces sites en
revanche on peut très bien imaginer
pourquoi pas de pousser cette logique
des quotas imaginé voilà tomeï vous avez
droit deux fois dans votre vie de
visiter la tour eiffel et pourquoi pas
vous avez la ville de venise qui vient
de mettre en place une taxe
je me souviens plus du montant c 4 5
euros c'est à dire que pour pouvoir
visiter venise vous devez payer cette
taxe à l'heure de jeu mon discrimination
c'est à dire qu'ils considèrent que
c'est des touristes d'un jour qui
portent préjudice à la série dc oui
c'est cela qui s'y met donc on assiste
bien une segmentation à viser certaines
populations et ce qui rejoint un petit
peu ce que vous dites jean viard il ya
un mouvement de fond qui est le
mouvement de la la société du du du
temps libre je pense que vous avez en
tête il ya celle ci vous avez comparé
les newsers d'autres les heures de
travail dans nos vies sous napoléon et
aujourd'hui ça donne quoi sous la peau
et non 3 70% de sa vie éveillée
aujourd'hui à pau - 2 1 % oui ces
chiffres là si vous voulez ça veut dire
qu'on est dans une société du temps
libre en gros l'essentiel de nos liens
sont plus dans le moment du travail
c'est à l'extérieur et je dirais la
qualité des temps libres fait la qualité
du travail on pourrait le dire comme ça
en gros quand vous avez fini de dormir
dehors mais deux cent mille heures ou
travailler 70 miller vous nous avez fait
trente mille heures d'études si vous
avez un peu plus que le bac
quand vous avez fini dormir de
travailler d'étudier vous avez consommé
trois cent mille heures de votre vie il
vous reste qu'à 100 miller pour faire
autre chose c'est ça la civilisation
moderne alors ça a récupéré les
mouvements religieux les tout ça sert
tous les autres temps libre qui existait
avant les manifestations les réserves à
avoir en cas d échec 1-1 mais ces
systèmes mais c'est très important mais
moi je rajouter une autre idée à nos
réflexions c'est justement sur le temps
qu'il faut beaucoup travailler prenez
une mesure simple on décide que tous les
parents ont droit d'enlever leurs
enfants une semaine de l'école en plus
des vacances scolaires parce que après
tout ces gens là libyenne pas pendant
huit jours par des contres les faits si
vous dites ça et si vous dites d'un coup
ben oui si vous vous la ramenez votre
gamin à venise aubin et le plus tôt en
novembre quand y'a personne qui a pas de
vacance est ce que les vacances
scolaires sont un gros cadors et en
france surtout ça on a extrêmement peur
il faut dire oui libérons si les parents
vous allez en voyage d'affaires je sais
pas au mois la raquette choix papa mac
et j'appelle d'affaires mais à
l'étranger bat pour autant mener ses
enfants et sa famille et puis partir une
semaine et je veux dire il faut et
inventer dans le temps il faut enlever
les cliquez sur le temps comme on parle
de l'espace il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire sur ces choses là on peut faire
s'effondrer les prix les prix des
locations en septembre et puis une
dernière remarque qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui habitent dans des
régions de vacances paris plages c'est
400 mille personnes je croise je me
trompe pas sur le chiffre dont 200
milles qu'ils ne partiront pas en
vacances
les villes de littoraux sur de plus en
plus peuplé et regarder ce qui se passe
à marseille tout ça on a fait des plages
partout etc il n'y a pas qu'à marseille
il ya de plus en plus de français qui
pendant leurs vacances ont des pratiques
de vacances tous les jours ils vont à la
plage le soir il mange une pizza avec un
verbe haut rose etc et puis sur les
bennes dormait chez eux on ne mesure que
l'hébergement or à mon avis c'est une
grosse erreur parce qu est ce qui compte
c'est les pratiques de vacances pour
effectivement cassé le rythme d'année
c'est pas forcément d'aller dormir
ailleurs avec une nouveauté sandra
hoibian qui est ce que tout ce que les
québécois soient que ces québécois qui
ont inventé le mot les tracks ans et
alors c'est une conséquence du
télétravail évidemment c'est un travail
sur son lieu de vacances c'est son idée
oui alors c'est inconséquent dit et
travail c'est aussi un lien avec les
questions écologiques c'est à dire on
essaye de limiter les déplacements
et puis c'est aussi une conséquence de
la période qu'ovide ou du coup on s'est
habitué à voir à d'autres rythmes et
notamment ce qu'on voit mais c'était
antérieure aux copines c'est qu'il ya
une progression du parc de résidences
secondaires et on voit qu'ils aient un
lien très net dans les études au crédoc
entre le télétravail et la résidence
secondaire plus on a de résidences
secondaires plus au télétravail et
inversement et donc il ya vraiment ce
phénomène où on va un petit peu rallongé
finalement lé week-end en travaillant un
ou deux jours dans sa résidence
secondaire parce qu'en fait ce sont un
peu les mêmes publiques qui sont pour
caricaturer plutôt aisée plutôt cadres
et qui ont donc accès aussi au
télétravail et à la résidence secondaire
parce qu'on est sur une petite partie de
la population a bien compris je vois un
dernier chapitre dans ce débat qui est à
la fois
conjoncturelles et structurelles puisque
c'est la question de la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et je propose à quand un
calme est de nous rejoindre
on va revenir pour commencer revens
warkentin sûr c'est cette grande
pagaille dans les aéroports parisiens au
tout début de ce mois voilà ça s'est vu
tout début du mois de juillet notamment
beaucoup à roissy charles de gaulle des
dizaines de vols annulés suite à une
grève portant sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail les salariés
mobilisés qui dénonçait un bien les bas
salaires alors que le groupe adp fait de
nouveau des profits ils dénoncent
également le manque d'effectifs ils
l'ont fait notamment dans un tweet que
je voulais vous montrer c'est la cgt de
roissy qui a ainsi twitté les patrons de
l'aérien ont supprimé plus de 10000
emplois cdi à charles de gaulle depuis
2020 leur projet faire transiter le
trafic passager de l'été 2010 9 mai avec
dix mille travailleurs en moins alors le
mouvement social s'est arrêté au bout de
six jours in extremis avant les grands
pics d'affluence avant les départs dans
les aéroports parisiens les salariés
parisiens qui ont obtenu 3 %
d'augmentation de salaire pour tout le
monde et puis on a vu ces images assez
impressionnante de milliers de bagages
voilà en attendant exactement des
dizaines de milliers de bagages se sont
retrouvés en souffrance à roissy charles
de gaulle après la grève 1 c'est une
raison mécanique au fait que avait
personne pour s'en occuper pendant
plusieurs heures certains sont toujours
thomas en déshérence douze jours plus
tard tous reviendront à leurs
propriétaires d'ici mercredi soir a
garanti la direction d'aéroports de
paris écoutez le pdg c'était ce matin
sur rmc je le dis lorsque il ya risque
d' apocalypse je le dis il n'y a pas de
risque d' apocalypse cet été on a des
équipes très mobilisé et encore une fois
je suis infiniment malheureux que cet
épisode du 1er juillet et créer cette
tâche dans notre image alors augustin de
romanet qui s'est excusé auprès des
utilisateurs des aéroports de paris
vraiment de façon très plate ce matin
sur rmc met donc on le voir les français
qui repartent massivement en ex en
vacances avec une hausse brutale du
trafic d'ailleurs dans cette interview
le pdg
dp dit qu'on est presque aux chiffres
2010 9 pour la fréquentation de ces
aéroports sauf que donc les effectifs
des équipes n'ont pas suivi des manques
d'effectifs qui touche thomas également
les compagnies aériennes elles peinent à
recruter depuis plusieurs mois et on a
vu certaines compagnies aériennes à
annuler des milliers de vols faute de
personnel la compagnie qui vont faire la
grève si la fin de semaine pour le
week-end ça en son sens celle qui part
en vacances etc et à s'agacer lionel
rabiet est-ce que vous avez alors
qu'est-ce questions au directeur de
voyages d'exception est ce que vous avez
encore des clients qui attendent leurs
bagages la non non non j'ai 10 ans tous
deux retrouvés voilà mes mais cela dit
moi je pense qu'il ya encore un risque
d' apocalypse d'abord parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le problème de charles de gaulle
il ya aussi le problème des aéroports en
média périphériques aujourd'hui à
amsterdam à londres vous avez des
problématiques qui sont encore plus
grave que celle qu'on vient de voir un
charles de gaulle et ça se répercute sur
les voyageurs sur ceux qui viennent en
france notamment et puis aussi le
problème de la police aux frontières
vous avez on parle aujourd'hui de temps
d'attentes pour les étrangers qui
viennent en france de plus de trois
heures à la police aux frontières pour
pouvoir passer toutes ces étapes
pénurie de personnel sont une pénurie de
personnel le système paraphe aujourd'hui
qui ébranle a tous vu qu'ils en panne
une fois sur deux oui c'est le système
automatique
j'ai entendu ce matin
monsieur durban et j'ai été heureux
d'apprendre que tout allait bien se
passer mais je pense qu'il faudra qu'on
fasse le bilan à la fin de l'été et sur
le moment il faut quand même vous les
voyageurs deviennent bien en avance à
l'aéroport
sans registre évidemment de chez eux
quand ils le peuvent et prennent toutes
les précautions possibles florent
manniez pourquoi cette pénurie de
personnel si on commence par le cas d'un
épais par exemple d'aéroports de paris
il ya eu un manque d'anticipation de la
reprise c'est quoi l'explication qu'a
phénomène structurel je pense que vous
pourrez confirmé mais personne ne
s'attendait à une reprise aussi rapide
donc il ya déjà ce premier phénomène
avec une offre une demande pardon qui a
crû de manière extrêmement importante et
en parallèle il ya quand même tout un
tas de procédure pour former les
personnels notamment dans les aéroports
cdd des procédures relativement long des
systèmes d'habilitation également on est
quand même sur une matière sensible donc
voilà c'est un une addition de
phénomènes qui
pour arriver à ce résultat et moi je
rejoint lionel rabhi je pense que le
risque de catastrophes existe bel et
bien on est sur des populations qui
payent des billets extrêmement cher qui
se retrouvent avec des suppléments
bagages jeux qui sont pas forcément
comprise dans les compagnies avec le
développement de politiques commerciales
qui brouillent complètement les repères
habituels donc il ya un vrai risque cet
été et des bagarres puisque la sphère
avait commencé à l'aéroport d'amsterdam
si je me rappelle bien avec des bagages
à amsterdam qui n'est pas réputée être
la destination la plus la moins calme
voilà donc ça des bagarres entre qui
sont des bagages c'était
vidéo
des vols annulés un accès les reports
qui est compliqué aujourd'hui vous
pouvez arriver à l'aéroport si vous
prenez un taxi alors si vous en trouvez
un
et vous arrivez à l'entrée de l'aéroport
et il faut 45 minutes pour que le taxi
arrive jusqu'au terminal donc tout ça
est source de stress évidemment et c'est
vrai qu'après que cette période où les
français ont
ceux qui ont la chance de pouvoir
voyager à l'étranger ne l'ont pas fait
c'est un peu triste finalement qui se
retrouvent confrontés à ses difficultés
c'est assez symptomatique des risques je
pense mais c'est vrai il faut il faut
dire les jaloux et la france maintenant
toute l'europe qui est concerné et c'est
des problématiques de fond effectivement
oui maintien de l'emploi dans la danse
et professionnellement je vais je vais
donner un chiffre pardon de vous
interrompre c'est le baromètre besoins
de main d'oeuvre de pôle emploi qui
donne ces chiffres 360 mille postes à
pourvoir mon secteur du tourisme dont
50% de deux saisonniers tiens on va vous
donner un exemple avec
l'extrait d'un reportage réalisé par
cécile 6 où c'était à lacanau le camping
à des camping de lacanau regarder ça des
profils elle peut très très peu
quelqu un peu plus d'expérience pour
pouvoir me défouler sur l'arrière c'est
pas évident sur ce service parce que
c'est un service malgré tout assez
exigeant
qu'ils n'ont pas mal d'expérience on a
jusqu'à 2300 vacanciers chaque année
avec des chassés-croisés importants
l'été le samedi le dimanche que mercredi
et donc du coup ça nécessite voilà des
personnes qui ont déjà une première
expérience je pense qu'on va réduire
clairement nos critères de recherche
pour pouvoir peut-être déjà donné la
chance à de nouvelles personnes qui ont
découvert le métier impossible en
revanche de donner sa chance sur des
postes comme ceux des maîtres nageurs ou
d'animateurs qui nécessitent des
diplômes
faire c'est super d'être équipé compris
c'est un garçon pour le bafa un poste au
mini club
c'est une personne avec le bafa donc du
coup ça va parfaitement bien compléter
l'équipe de douze animateurs
pour la responsable du service qui fait
passer des entretiens locaux vides a eu
un impact les jeunes refusent des
conditions de travail trop difficile on
est quand même sur sûrement métier
touristique donc avec une une charge de
travail qui est compensée qui est
intense ça dure deux mois et tous pas
sur ces deux mois là donc c'est vrai que
c'est quand même ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie et je pense qu'effectivement
avec le co lead il ya une prise de
conscience et et et beaucoup de jeunes
ont envie peut-être d'un peu plus
profiter de leurs étés ou de faire un
peu moins d'heures tout en ayant même
salaire par
sandra hoibian pourquoi ce secteur est
le plus impacté où l'un des plus
impactée par la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qui est quand même assez générale il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs touchés
alors déjà effectivement il ya une
reprise de l'emploi donc en fait le
salarié est un peu plus en position de
force il l'a plutôt aller vers les
emplois où il ya des conditions de
travail qui sont les plus favorables or
dans le secteur du tourisme et
d'hôtellerie restauration il ya
énormément de turnover il ya un tiers à
peu près du salarié mais salariés qui
sont renouvelés chaque année donc du
coup ce qui s'est passé c'est que
pendant la période qu'ovide les nouveaux
entrants ne sont pas entrés en fait
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu un déficit de
jeunes qui sont allés vers le tourisme
qui se sont formés et donc à l'arrivée
aujourd'hui il ya moins de personnes qui
sont en capacité de travailler et puis
il ya aussi
des pratiques dans l'industrie
touristique qui gagnerait à être un
petit peu améliorée au tour comment la
question des salaires alors il ya eu une
augmentation à l'air bon sens et sol les
salaires je crois que c'est évidemment
un élément important mais il ya aussi
tout ce qui est par exemple les
questions d'horaires donc avoir des
horaires qui soit plus plus agréable
donc il ya des restaurateurs par exemple
prix qui rassemble les services pour que
les gens aient des journées qui soit
plus plus compact et qu'ils aient pas un
temps de pause entre deux dons qu'il ya
des choses à faire mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions de travail
et puis il ya aussi un élément la
réforme du chômage d'une certaine
manière donc a réduit il faut maintenant
voir si moi en fait pour pouvoir accéder
aux allocations chômage et donc
mécaniquement ça a réduit le le pool des
saisonniers lionel rabiet c'est
structurel
c'est qu'il ya un accord qui a été signé
par exemple avec le gouvernement
tunisien pourrait revenir dès des
salariés lors ce sera plutôt pour la
saison prochaine d'après ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai compris est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est que voilà cette situation
qu'on est en train de vivre elle peut
durer longtemps plusieurs saisons dont
le genre je ne pense pas que c'est
structurel c'est vrai que le métier du
voyage et du tourisme a un peu été pris
de court parce que pendant deux ans
effectivement où on a été on a on a dû
mettre du personnel au chômage passent l
on a eu une fuite vraiment
du personnel et cette reprise assez
rapide n'a pas permis finalement de
remettre en route la machine la machine
anglais après ça reste des métiers qui
doivent être pensés pour être plus
attractif
c'est des métiers qui doit être aussi
revaloriser et donc aujourd'hui si je
prends ma casquette entreprises du
voyage on est on va proposer dans notre
secteur d augmentation importante des
minima conventionnels donc je pense qu'à
long terme il n'y a rien qui peut gêner
la reprise de l'emploi simplement
effectivement il naissait à nous en tant
que l'employeur d'apporter des
conditions de travail qui correspondent
aux attentes des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
des moins jeunes on va terminer là
dessus merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau et vous aussi jean vierge
versité votre livre l'an zéro du
tourisme penser l'avenir après la grande
pandémie publié aux éditions de l'aube